[Music]
vanessa bryant's legal battle against
l.a county continues and things are
heating up inside the courtroom with a
fire captain who was at the site of kobe
bryant's helicopter crash walking off
the witness stand multiple times
a trial centered on law enforcement's
conduct is underway vanessa bryant was
visibly emotional during wednesday's
proceedings crying frequently
vanessa's suing over graphic photos
taken and shared for personal use by the
sheriff's and fire department of her
late husband and their daughter gianna
who both tragically died in a helicopter
crash in january 2020 we love and miss
you boo boo and gigi former fire captain
brian jordan took the stand to testify
on monday and cited stress from working
the crash site as his reason for
repeatedly excusing himself from the
witness stand
quote the way the whole scene looked
that's going to haunt me forever
after photos were shown of the victim's
remains brian rejected questions about
which picks he took and claimed a
supervisor asked him to take sight
photos as part of the fire department's
protocol
vanessa's lawyer says brian stepped out
with his legal team three times during
the court proceedings and when asked
where kobe's body was among the remains
he reportedly said i need a break sorry
your honor
as for why well jordan's attorney says
the frequent breaks were a result of a
medical condition that developed that
left him with severe trauma bryant's
attorney also told jurors the photos
were virtual gossip and played security
video of an off-duty sheriff's deputy
showing them to a bartender to support
that claim
that off-duty deputy joey cruz who also
took the stand monday he too was accused
of sharing photos at the scene
during questioning cruz who was a
trainee at the time admitted he took it
too far and called it something i
shouldn't have done
and while vanessa continues to mourn her
husband and daughter's deaths she's
staying strong surrounded by the love
and support of her closest friends
like lala anthony who continues to stick
by vanessa's side i tell her every day
she's the strongest woman i know and
i'm really really proud of just
how she's handling everything and just
want to continue to be there you know as
much as i can for her as a friend
and the bryants have been leaning on
each other through it all back in march
e.t caught up with vanessa and kobe's
eldest daughter natalia who continues to
persevere
attending usc and following her
hollywood dreams i've learned the most
just from each other
i think just being able to rely on each
other and be there for each other has
been like the biggest inspiration
[Music]
you